[Música]
empezaba por donde te lleve la corriente
pero lo importante es que empecé y que
empecé es ya
como por ejemplo cuando yo recibí mi
primer cheque a nombre de una empresa
que todavía no existía por un negocio en
el que vendía una marca que todavía no
había creado
y así fue el inicio de mi emprendimiento
hace 9 años
miren
los emprendimientos pueden tener un
camino corto un camino largo yo les voy
a platicar la versión corta utilizando
tres preguntas tres preguntas que yo he
aprendido a lo largo de mi carrera y que
recomiendo ustedes se hagan al momento
de emprender de iniciar cualquier
proyecto personal la primera de ellas es
que tanto que tanto estás dispuesto a
hacer
estás dispuesto a sangrar estás
dispuesto a tirarte al agua
o realmente estás dispuesto a cruzar te
todo un océano
en mi caso yo si me lo crucé
decidimos con mi esposa y mi bebé de dos
meses irnos a vivir a china
acababa de renunciar de mi trabajo no
teníamos muchos ahorros no hablábamos
mandarín pero necesitaba completar el
proyecto que les contenga un inicio el
del cheque se recuerdan
como no teníamos muchos fondos tuvimos
que buscar un lugar bastante económico
para vivir nos fuimos a un complejo muy
bonito en donde vivíamos más o menos
tres a cuatro mil personas era un lugar
no tan turístico por lo tanto nosotros
siendo turistas ahí nos convertimos en
los extraños del lugar entonces pues nos
tomaban fotos éramos bastante
reconocidos en la zona sobre todo a mi
hijo cuando salí a jugar los agentes de
seguridad le tomaban fotos porque decían
que tenía los ojos muy grandes
y miren ustedes
el camino no fue color de rosa
se recuerdan del primer proyecto bueno
ninguna fábrica en china me lo quiso
recibir porque el pedido era muy pequeño
y en china pues se hablan de cantidades
de miles de unidades para poder producir
pero como todo buen emprendedor pues
tenemos plan plan b o algunos hasta plan
z verdad
tuve que recurrir a mi plan b
y este consistía en ir a un mercado que
yo había conocido de hecho es el mercado
de electrónicos más grandes del mundo
este es un mercado lleno de edificios
son cuadras de cuadras cada cuadra tiene
muchos edificios y dentro de los
edificios hay quioscos hay locales y
todos están repletos de piezas
electrónicas que le pueden servir a uno
para armar desde un celular hasta una
televisión entonces pues me fui a
recorrerlo y me llevé la sorpresa que
ahí yo podía encontrar todas las piezas
que me servían para completar el
producto que yo le había ofrecido al
cliente eso sí no era un producto
terminado sino que me tocaba que comprar
todas las piezas por separado y pues me
iba a tocar que ensamblar las por mi
cuenta así que bueno continué con ese
plan
y alguien y un cuartito ahí mismo en el
mercado un cuartito pequeño como de 3
metros cuadrados y me llevé la gran
sorpresa que me estaba ahorrando como un
30 40 por ciento del costo al hacerlo yo
mismo y lo mejor de todo es que había
encontrado un nicho de mercado de
clientes que estaban buscando poder
producir cantidades pequeñas de
productos electrónicos personalizados y
lo mejor lo mejor es que yo había
encontrado la fórmula para poderles
atender así que bueno no les voy a
mentir la verdad es que si me tocó que
echar punta trabajaba 15 16 horas al día
me tenían recorriendo las calles del
mercado con mis carretones llevaban
materia prima de un lado para otro pero
así son todos los inicios así empezamos
a crecer empezamos a trabajar duro y con
el paso del tiempo pasamos de una
plantita en tres metros cuadrados a un
lugar mucho más formal totalmente
adaptado para tener una mejor
y esta es una planta guatemalteca en
china con el paso de los meses nos
trajimos ese conocimiento a guatemala y
empezamos a ensamblar aquí también
miren ustedes esto me lleva a la segunda
pregunta
qué tan dispuestos están ustedes a creer
a creer en ustedes mismos pero más que
eso en el feeling que nosotros como
emprendedores tenemos en el olfato de
emprendedor y les voy a contar una
historia a mí me sucedió que llevábamos
5 o 6 años ya trabajando
se nos dio la oportunidad de abrir
nuestra primera tienda nuestra primera
tienda física un showroom
como todo soñador
yo me acerqué con varios amigos cercanos
y les decía mira vos yo quisiera que el
día que abra una tienda
la gente llegue una noche antes y haga
cola y acampe afuera de la tienda para
entrar de primero y la verdad es que la
respuesta de la gran mayoría era nombre
kevin cálmate eso no va a pasar
tu marca es una marca relativamente
nueva no es tan reconocida
los que logran ese tipo de efectos son
marcas internacionales son marcas que
vienen de afuera a guatemala y causan
ese tipo de sensación
yo recibí esos mensajes como ok están
tratando de cuidarme y me decían mira
mejor pensar tranquilo solo abrir la
tienda si no te vas a decepcionar de ver
que los resultados no se dan así que me
deje llevar y pues simplemente hicimos
unas cuantas publicaciones anunciando
que íbamos a abrir un jueves a las 6 de
la tarde
publicaciones en redes sociales así que
ese jueves llegamos
34 trabajadores de la empresa a decorar
la tienda a poner el producto y todo
porque dijimos tenemos tiempo abrimos
hasta las 6 tipo 7 y media de la mañana
ustedes de repente se asoma una persona
por la puerta y se sienta en la parte de
afuera de la tienda y nosotros con mucha
pena vamos y le decimos mire fíjese que
clara es que vamos a abrir hasta las 6
no no a las 8 y la respuesta de esta
persona fue no no no es que yo quiero
ser el primero y nosotros como chica
bueno
más o menos nueve nueve y media de la
mañana ya habían cinco personas haciendo
cola así que no dio pena y pusimos unas
lonas azules para que no nos vieran
decorarla
miren ustedes cuando tipo 11 de la
mañana hicimos así la cortina de la lona
azul que habíamos puesto
y habían 50 personas en la cola tipo 2
de la tarde ustedes ya habían
100 personas tipo 4 de la tarde y habían
como 200 afuera ya tuvimos que salir a
poner un cordón y todo miren cuando se
dio la hora de la apertura a las 6 de la
tarde de verdad habían más de 300
personas afuera queriendo entrar y saben
que la tienda era de menos de 30 metros
cuadrados realmente no teníamos ni cómo
meter a toda la gente en la tienda pero
el sueño que yo no que que yo me eche
para atrás el sueño se me estaba
cumpliendo
y a partir de esta experiencia yo me
prometí que iba a escuchar consejos
porque los consejos siempre son buenos
pero que nunca iba a dejar de creer en
mi olfato emprendedor en el feeling en
el instinto que uno tiene cuando está
echando punta porque esto hubiese sido
una bomba si lo hubiéramos organizado
como mi sueño me lo decía
por supuesto fue muy bonito
estas experiencias
me llevan a la tercera pregunta
y a ver
cuando emprendemos será que necesitamos
tener el propósito claro
el propósito de lo que vamos a hacer con
nuestro emprendimiento la realidad es
que si lo tenemos claro y bien definido
es ideal pero eso no pasa la gran
cantidad de veces así que la realidad es
que es que no es necesario
hay que dejarse llevar por la corriente
y les aseguro que con el paso del tiempo
van a ir encontrando ese propósito
a nosotros nos sucedió llevábamos seis
años operando éramos un negocio rentable
vendíamos pero no estábamos
trascendiendo no estábamos dejando un
legado no estábamos haciendo historia
cuando de repente empezamos a escuchar
de verdad escuchar a ver a leer lo que
nuestros clientes nos decían nos
mostraban en fotos nos preguntaban los
mismos clientes
seis años después
los mismos clientes nos iban diciendo el
significado de nosotros para ellos a
través de mensajes y preguntas que nos
hacían
empezamos a ver fotografías en donde
habían personas utilizando nuestros
productos mensajes en donde nos decían
miren ustedes son guatemaltecos y están
haciendo un producto de tan buena
calidad
personas que nos mandaban mensajes
diciendo qué orgullo tener un producto
guatemalteco qué orgullo que los diseños
sean guatemaltecos miren ustedes
personas en lugares astrales en todo el
mundo
publicando en sus redes sociales fotos y
vídeos utilizando nuestros productos así
que un día nos sentamos
y gracias a los clientes
y seis años después
pasamos de esto
a esto muchas gracias